I want set the record straight about penis
bones.
Walruses have the prestigious distinction
of having the largest ones on the planet.
Penis bones – or bacula – are enigmatic
structures that are possessed by males of
various species across several mammalian orders.
They aren’t true bones inasmuch as they
are actually derived from outside of the skeleton
– from connective tissue that forms at the
very tip of the penis.
Despite the fact that walruses have kind of
won the evolutionary lottery of the penis
bone – scientists cannot come to a specific
agreement as to their exact function.
The leading hypothesis as to the original
function of the baculum is in helping to maintain
erections.
You can imagine that the Northern oceans (where
mammals with the largest penis bones are found)
are quite cold, and copulations most often
occur in the freezing water.
Copulation on land does happen sometimes and
it comes with its own hazards…
I mean, have you seen a walrus?
If things get a little rough (as they often
do), delicate phalluses could easily be crushed.
So the bacula help to ensure that penises
remain intact and functional.
Female preference is another important aspect
of penis-bone biology.
In addition to facilitating the maintenance
of erections and providing penis protection,
there are aspects of baculum morphology that
are shaped by what the ladies like.
After all, if a baculum is shaped in such
a way that it stimulates and pleasures the
females, it follows that males with said bacula
will be more likely to score.
Others species have smaller, but much more
intricate bacula with spines, hooks and curves.
Interestingly, the penis bones of walruses,
sea lions and polar bears are termed OOSIKs
in Native Alaska cultures and they are used
as handles for tools.
This is the pretty much extent of human interaction
with penis bones, as our species no longer
possesses them - even though some of our closest
primate relatives do.
So unlike the animals gifted with bacula,
human males have to perform without this added
advantage.
If you want to see more copulation creations,
check out this Wild Sex playlist!
Let us know in the comments what animal sex
stories you want to see.
If you want more stories right now, grab a
copy of the book Wild Sex, written by me,
Dr. Carin Bondar.
Thanks for watching and make sure to subscribe!